[Musique]
mère déchaîné intempéries enneigement
les conditions météo impactent le
quotidien des forces pour des jouets ces
phénomènes les armées ont un allié de
taille la météorologie une science
complexe qui se révèle essentielle à la
conduite des missions un enjeu
stratégique majeur
sur le terrain et en opération les 300
météorologues militaires réalisent
quotidiennement les prévisions
nécessaires aux forces
analyse satellite et calcule
l'atmosphérique sont effectuées en
permanence pour assurer la sécurité de
tous et le bon déroulé de la mission
sur terre en mer ou dans les airs les
météorologues représentent un atout de
taille pour les forces
le journal de la défense vous amène à la
rencontre de ceux qui font la pluie et
le beau temps dans nos armées
[Musique]
le 26 janvier 2016 le moderne Express un
navire de transport de plus de 10000
tonnes lance un appel de détresse il se
trouve au large du golfe de Gascogne
dans les eaux territoriales espagnoles
les membres de l'équipage sont secourus
par des militaires espagnols mais le
cargo est hors de contrôle et des rives
dangereusement vers les côtes françaises
menaçants de s'échouer une opération de
remorquage de grande ampleur et
déclenchée par le préfet maritime de
l'Atlantique allié à la Marine nationale
un câble de plusieurs centaines de
mètres doit être posée sur le navire
pour être tracté par un remorqueur
là on est sur un cargo à la dérive en
plein golf de Gascogne le golf de
Gascogne par mauvaise météo c'est les
conditions de mer extrêmement rugueuses
et conditions de vent extrêmement
rugueuses et l'opération de remorquage
en elle-même elle est excessivement
difficile il faut à la fois s'approcher
très près avec des mouvements relatifs
liés à l'état de maire qui sont très
importants mais également mettre des
gens à bord pour venir capeler cette
remorque sur la plage avant du bateau le
fait que le bateau soit non manœuvrant
c'est un exercice qui est pas facile il
faut s'adapter aux conditions du moment
le vent il peut tourner le bateau fait
des embarets non maîtrisés et donc
réussir un triage précis dans un point
précis et d'autant plus compliqué
à son bord 300 tonnes de fioul menacent
de se déverser dans la mer la préfecture
maritime décide d'intervenir le 29
janvier un premier câble est posé mais
la mauvaise météo complexifie la mission
et sous la pression le câble se casse
trois jours plus tard le capitaine de
frégate Jérôme est mobilisée pour tenter
une nouvelle opération bute de la
mission rattaché un nouveau filin pour
le remorquage pour notre première
préoccupation c'est de se dire mais
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire quelque
chose est-ce qu'il va pas sombrer ce qui
menaçait vraiment de sombrer on avait
une porte qui était plus ou moins
ouverte qui laissait entrer de l'eau on
se demandait déjà comment ça se fait
qu'il tenait encore et pour combien de
temps et donc on a en mémoire toutes les
catastrophes de ces cargo ou pétroliers
qui qui s'échouent avec derrière des
enjeux économiques écologiques très
important donc je pense à les Rica
comme le navire n'était pas en route
cette gîte de 40 à 52 degrés elle varier
donc on avait un mouvement de roulis
assez important le choix qu'on a fait
pour le triage c'était de se mettre face
au vent relatif on n'est pas le choix et
effectivement de suivre ce mouvement il
fallait qu'on pose notre plongeur non
pas sur un pont mais sur les parois du
bateau le bateau était couché on savait
pas s'il allait couler ou pas
car mon plongeur descendait et se
promener sur les parois du bateau on
peut dire ça comme ça pour réaliser sa
mission j'avais qu'une appréhension
c'est que le bateau commence à sombrer
la seconde tentative est un succès le
premier février le moderne Express est
rattaché au remorqueur espagnol qui le
conduit au port de Bilbao
et on a réussi à alors que le modèle
Express était à 50 nautique des côtes un
peu par chance on a une fenêtre météo au
bon moment s'il y avait pas eu cette
fenêtre météo on aurait prolon les
choumont
du Modern Express
tous cette coordination de différents
acteurs qui ont apporté chacun leur
expertise chacun leur savoir-faire on
fait la réussite de cette opération
assez exceptionnelle de ce côté-là
remorqueur frégate anti sous-marine et
hélicoptères ont opéré ensemble ils ont
su s'adapter aux conditions
météorologiques pour éviter le pire
une collaboration entre forces civile et
militaires également présente à Toulouse
où le site de Météo France accueille le
6mf Centre interarmé de soutien météo
océanographique des forces
créées en 2009 il est le résultat de la
fusion des centres météo de chacune des
armées
24 heures sur 24 et 365 jours par an il
fournit des informations météo au profit
des opérations menées partout dans le
monde le centre est composé de trois
pôles donc le pôle principal qui assure
la mission principale qui est le pôle
opération avec la salle opération qui
est armée H24 par du personnel des trois
armées et un ingénieur Météo France
ensuite nous avons un pôle développement
expertise
qui suit les grands programmes du
domaine et qui développe aussi certains
outils spécifiques à l'utilisation des
prévisionnistes des armées et enfin nous
avons le pôle formation qui est notre
deuxième grande mission ici nous formons
les prévisionnistes et les prévisions
c'est un graphe des trois armées pendant
18 mois de formation initiale
pour ces productions le 6 émet utilise
les données du supercalculateur de Météo
France un ordinateur surpuissant capable
de réaliser des milliards de calculs à
la seconde une aide précieuse qui permet
de donner aux forces déployées les
prévisions les plus précises qui soient
aucune opération se prépare aujourd'hui
sans qu'on ait regardé de près
la météorologie et les conséquences que
ça va avoir sur l'opération est-ce qu'on
va pouvoir utiliser la météorologie à
notre profit ou est-ce que ça va être
une gêne pour la réalisation de
l'opération tout ça est étudié en amont
et pendant en permanence on remet à jour
ou en permanence la prévision pour que
l'opération se déroule dans les
meilleures conditions possibles en salle
opération l'activité ne s'arrête jamais
les spécialistes réalisent des
prévisions pour les militaires projetés
n'importe où sur le globe deux jours
comme de nuit il se relaient pour
qu'aucun phénomène ne passe entre les
mailles du filet
donc c'est une salle où vous avez en
permanence 5 personnels donc vous avez
un superviseur un ingénieur Météo France
et trois prévisionnistes de l'armée donc
que ce soit armée de l'air de la Marine
nationale ou de l'armée de terre puisque
nous sommes à un centre intérieur
de mourir progressivement il était
surtout actif à la semaine dernière elle
est le weekend et passer sur la Réunion
et voilà il est bien au sud de
Madagascar
la France possède le deuxième plus grand
domaine maritime au monde son territoire
s'étend sur plus de 10 millions de
kilomètres carrés l'enjeu stratégique
est majeur les armées doivent
constamment surveiller les océans pour
permettre au bâtiment de la Marine
d'effectuer leur mission en toute
sécurité le seum Service hydrographique
national et l'opérateur français de
référence basé à Brest une antenne est
déployée ici à Toulouse nous on
travaille sur une des missions du seum
qui est le soutien à la défense et
notamment le soutien la Marine nationale
en fournissant au quotidien de manière
opérationnelle les prévisions
aussianographiques donc au profit des
bâtiments de surface et des sous-marins
le méthaque en plus d'être météorologue
il est
océanographe c'est-à-dire qu'il a une
connaissance du domaine maritime et il
est capable d'expertiser
tous les phénomènes qui auront lieu soit
la surface soit sur toute la colonne
d'eau y compris les états de mer mais ça
va des cours en mar jusqu'aux évolutions
des caractéristiques des masses d'eau la
température la salinité la célérité qui
ont tout un impact à un moment ou un
autre sur les différentes luttes de que
peut mener la Marine nationale
[Musique]
expert en météorologie et océanographies
la France fait partie des nations les
plus performantes un savoir-faire
transmis à le nm et colle national de
météorologie une formation exigeante
dispensée sur le site de Météo France ou
ce que toi civil et militaire
[Musique]
pendant 18 mois les jeunes militaires
rejoignent les bancs de l’école il
bénéficie des mêmes instructions que
leur camarades civils seuls différences
des cours accès météorologiques
militaires et un semestre consacré au
phénomène météo de leur arme
d'appartenance au total 250 élèves
civils et militaires sont formés ici
chaque année
bonne condition
le brouillard on avait jusqu'à 100
mètres de visibilité minimum après ça
évolué donc avec une visibilité qui est
augmentée ou fur et à mesure des
échéances jusqu'à 7 heures 50
l'avantage pour les élèves militaires de
participer à cette formation et d'avoir
accès à la fois aux enseignements des
spécialistes de Météo France que ce soit
des anciennes anglaism ou d'autres
services qui viennent intervenir dans
les formations des enseignants qui
peuvent avoir une expérience amont dans
des services de prévision et des
services de coopérationnel de Météo
France et qui vont pouvoir transmettre
tout ce qu'ils ont appris de leur
expérience aux élèves militaires
et à vous souvenez le principe de cette
instrument
c'est le diamètre
entre pratiquer théories les élèves
militaires se mettent en conditions
réelles pour apprendre toutes les
ficelles du métier mathématiques
physiques de l'atmosphère et analyse
prévision ces météorologues en devenir
suivent une formation très dense nous
avons un parié mardi de Beyrouth et nous
serons samedi en Israël Haïfa
donc actuellement à neufz où nous avons
présent ce de cumulonimbus avec une mère
qui est agitée due à une houle de
secteur Ouest au niveau de cette
formation
avec tout d'abord un semestre avec des
matières théoriques ensuite pendant le
deuxième semestre c'est plutôt un
semestre pratique où on va par exemple
aller faire de l'observation comme un
tour d'observation et également on est
plus du côté militaire on fait on
commence à faire les briefings et après
en troisième semestre c'est là qu'on
attaque plutôt la partie coeur de métier
donc propre à chaque armée donc pour
l'armée de terre et l'armée de l'air
c'est plus tout ce qui est météo
aéronautique surtout alors que pour la
marine on va voir donc déjà météo
aéronautique et également tout ce qui
est le sous-marine et on fait également
toutes les armées ce qu'on appelle la
détection électromagnétique à la fin de
leur cursus les jeunes militaires
obtiennent un diplôme reconnu par
l'Organisation Mondiale de la
météorologie une récompense pour ses
élèves qui s'apprêtent à faire partie
d'une spécialité qui a marqué l'histoire
représente aujourd'hui un maillon
essentiel des forces quand on regarde un
peu l'histoire on se rend compte que le
fait météorologique il est apparu
plusieurs fois comme assez important
dans un certain nombre de faits des
batailles navales ou des batailles
terrestres mais le fait marquant pour la
France c'est pendant la guerre de Crimée
ou 41 bâtiments de la Marine ont coulé
suite à une tempête qui a ravagé toute
l'Europe de l'Ouest
cette tempête n'avait pas été averti
donc n'ont pas pu se préparer à son
impact ce qui a entraîné de ce naufrage
massif
suite à ce drame survenu en 1854 les
armées réalisent l'importance de la
prise en compte de la météo dans leurs
opérations des stations météo sont alors
installées un peu partout en Europe et
la marine oblige ses équipages à relever
toutes les conditions rencontrées en mer
dans un carnet de bord
le premier service météorologique
militaire des armées a été créée pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale en 1916 avec
la montée en puissance de l'aviation
donc on est héritier aujourd'hui de ce
service militaire de météorologie qui a
vécu sous plusieurs formes avec une
forte montée en puissance pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale on a parlé de
guerre météorologiques en particulier
l'exemple le plus marquant c'est le
débarquement Normandie le 6 juin 44 ou
là le fait météo a été décortiqué pour
donner un avantage aux Alliés lors de ce
débarquement
initialement prévue le 5 juin les
prévisionnistes demandent le report de
l'opération en cause une perturbation
annoncée au large des côtes françaises
[Musique]
grâce à une fenêtre météo favorable le
débarquement est finalement lancé dans
la nuit du 5 au 6 juin
digne
héritier d'un savoir-faire qui a changé
le cours de nombreuses opérations les
météorologues d'aujourd'hui poursuivent
le travail initié par leurs aînés
[Musique]
sur la base aérienne de Cognac
l'adjudant-chef Didier connaît bien les
rouages et l'exigence de la météo chaque
matin le rituel est le même il prépare
ses prévisions à partir d'images
satellites anticyclone dépression
température tous les phénomènes sont
passés au crible car avant chaque vol
les conditions météo font partie
intégrante de la préparation mission
alors le matin quand nous arrivons donc
à la station météo une des premières
choses que nous faisons c'est ouvrir
comme vous le voyez ici une image
satellite à l'échelle de l'Europe pour
avoir une vision très globale du temps
d'un premier coup d'oeil là par exemple
ce matin nous voyons que sur sur la
France et l'Europe il n'y a pas de front
pas de perturbation et très peu de pluie
voire pas de pluie une fois l'analysé
effectuée débriefings météo sont
présentés aux unités crise sanitaire
oblige il se tiennent en distanciel ici
le briefing est à destination des
pilotes de drone
bonjour je vous présente la météo de
cette journée donc toujours des
conditions anticycloniques 1033 le
dernier QNH et dans la continuité du
temps d'hier beaucoup d'humidité dans
les basses couches l'effet de
l'anticyclone divers pour une même météo
les données transmises aux équipages
dépendront du type de mission et
d'aéronef un pilote d'avion de chasse
n'aura pas besoin des mêmes informations
qu'un pilote de drone le chasseur
demandera par exemple davantage de
donner pour un vol à haute altitude
contrairement au drone qui lui évoluera
plus bas
la météorologie aéronautique sur une
base aérienne et là pour spécifier les
phénomènes dangereux de voilà en premier
lieu c'est ça c'est faire éviter au
pilote et son aéronef les zones
dangereuses les nuages dangereux le
givrage la turbulence les rafales les
décharges électriques dans un orage et
ensuite ça lui permet de réaliser sa
mission dans les meilleures conditions
et la spécificité du de ce métier au
sein de l'armée c'est que nous
travaillons plus dans les coulisses dans
le soutien et sans nous l'activité n'est
pas possible dégradée
jusqu'à la dernière minute les
météorologues répondent présents ils
assurent un rôle de conseil auprès des
pilotes pour préparer au mieux son vol
le sous-lieutenant de Jason vient
questionner le spécialiste météo
donc à quelle heure des collez vous
exactement on décolle à 16h35 local ok
donc voyez cognac ici toujours cette
couche adjectée en flux nord-est les
bonnes conditions il faut aller les
chercher clairement dans le côté Massif
central pour être assez en altitude pour
être au-dessus de la couche pour le
pilote les conseils de l'adjudant chef
jouent un rôle clé dans sa préparation
mission
la météo est très importante donc dans
notre quotidien en tant que pilote de
chasse car elle conditionne notre
préparation de mission savoir quel
profil de mission nous allons adopter
savoir si cela va être du vol à vue du
vol aux instruments et également savoir
si certains exercices seront réalisables
ou non des fois les missions sont
annulées causes de la météo et
effectivement à l'heure du décollage la
météo était plutôt bonne et alors
estimée d'atterrissage la météo c'était
clairement dégradée donc si nous étions
partis nous aurions eu du souci à se
faire pour se poser à Cognac
moi alors la base des nuages va s'élever
vraiment tranquillement là pour le
moment on a 100 pieds ça va monter à 300
pieds en fin de matinée la dernière ici
j'ai 200 donc je dirais que en début
d'après-midi c'est ok pour moi c'est le
terrain est propre à Limoges et chez
nous on aura j'espère qu'en début
d'après-midi on aura quelque chose comme
400 bonne journée à vous au revoir
passionné de météo l'adjudant chef
Didier ne se contente pas seulement
d'orienter les pilotes depuis 11 ans il
partage ses prévisions avec les
meilleurs athlètes français de nombreux
sports comme le ski alpin le biathlon ou
encore le combiné nordique je travaille
avec l'équipe de France militaire de ski
depuis maintenant c'est la 11e année et
ça c'est fait
par hasard on va dire sur un réseau
social
lex lieutenant Martin Fourcade il y a 11
ans écrivait nous allons en Allemagne et
il va faire mauvais moi j'ai regardé de
mon côté j'ai vu qu'il allait faire beau
donc je lui ai répondu non il va faire
beau et aussi simplement que ça ça s'est
avéré exact ma prévision et le lundi il
m'écrivait il m'a dit bon il faut qu'on
travaille ensemble il y a il y a
vraiment quelque chose à creuser tous
les deux une collaboration unique et
qu'il a poursuivi en février dernier
pour les Jeux Olympiques d'hiver mais à
cause de la crise sanitaire
l'adjudant-chef a du conseiller les
athlètes à distance de nuit à partir de
4 heures du matin il se met enneigé et
le résultat c'est que tu auras 3 cm au
réveil par moins de degrés toujours
c'est pour la glisse des skis
principalement pour qu'un ski glisse sur
sur de la neige il faut que on adapte
des produits sous ce ski et ça dépend
complètement et uniquement les
conditions météorologiques donc je suis
là pour conseiller
partout de Parlement et sur 4 mois
d'hiver tous ces sportifs à faire des
meilleurs performances possibles et
comme le disait un jour Martin Fourcade
lui-même
l'aide de Didier c'est pas celle qui te
fait gagner mais c'est celle qui te fait
ne pas perdre
présent lors des JO de 2014 et 2018
Didier a pu vivre l’aventure olympique
jusque sur les bords de pistes il a
ainsi permis à l'équipe de France de
bénéficier de son expertise météo
[Musique]
à l'image des athlètes les groupements
commando parachutistes n'ont qu'un seul
objectif mené à bien la mission
n'importe où et n'importe quand les GCP
sont opérationnels ils ont appris à
composer avec la météo voire même en
faire un allié de taille
décrocher son abdominale et de la
raccrocher pour éviter qu'elle soit
ouvrier que si on vient sur le côté on
se rend compte que la sangle abdominale
devra sauter elle va jusque loin
derrière donc en fait elle peut se
vriller ici sans demi-brise sans faire
attention
les conditions sont évaluées pour
aborder l'opération au mieux un bulletin
complet et détaillé et transmis par le
sixième F de Toulouse sur place un
commando en douce le rôle de leader en
reprenant toutes les informations
données comme la force et la direction
du vent il réalise des calculs qui
déterminent si les équipes pourront
sauter encore une fois là ce que tu as
mis c'est de la Sécu il est pas censé
arriver jusque là il devrait peut-être
sortir un petit peu avant lui tu
calcules l'intervalle plus de la
circulaire
un état des lieux de la situation est
présenté à l'adjudant Bastien
instructeur de Sceaux là ce qu'on vient
de faire c'est que le leader a fait ses
calculs en fonction de son message météo
et du coup vient de présenter là à
l'insolt l'instructeur socr pour valider
ou pas on parle de partie de sécurité et
ensuite pour pouvoir aider à mieux
adapter le
l'infiltration de souverain et en
fonction des calculs en fonction des
contraintes qu'on a à partir de là
en plus des brief météo les commandos
sont à l'affût et scrutent le ciel en
permanence dès que les conditions le
permettent un vol est
déclenchée sur la zone et là on voit à
l'heure actuelle de cette couche
nuageuse en fait avec le Forza en l'air
ne tient pas forcément face à nous et ce
délit peut-être un petit peu et donc du
coup peut-être favorable à nos
infiltrations souvent notre entraînement
et au saut notamment et là on part
rapidement embarqué dans dans une
demi-heure on est dans la machine pour
les premiers déco on enchaîne
[Musique]
il est des vents en hauteur une fois en
l'air
la 25 degrés objectifs du jour réaliser
des infiltrations sous voile
cette technique nécessite une grande
précision la chienne dizaine de
kilomètres d'un endroit donné les
commandos doivent utiliser les vents et
les courants pour se porter jusqu'au
point d'impact un exercice périlleux
qu'ils sont amenés à reproduire en
opération extérieure
parmi les parachutistes à avoir fait le
grand saut ce matin le
lieutenant-colonel Frédéric 28 ans
d'armée au compteur pour lui une
mauvaise météo s’avère parfois être une
bonne nouvelle les commandos de parlant
en mission ont besoin justement
quelquefois d'avoir une mauvaise météo
pour remplir la mission dans les
meilleures conditions possibles pour pas
se faire des tester par l'ennemi pour
pas se faire déceler par les moyens
aériens de l'ennemi une météo
défavorable à souhait avec de la pluie
du vent de la neige finalement favorise
les possibilités d'infiltration et
d'action sur l'adversaire
en jeu stratégique la météo n’influence
pas uniquement les sceaux en opération
tous les paramètres doivent être évalués
pour que rien ne soit laissé au hasard
la météo on apprend en compte c'est en
prendre en compte pour ces contraintes
on est sur en faire devenir aussi des
avantages
par différentes manières que ce soit par
le vent la position du soleil et la
position de la Lune le vent notamment
pour tout ce qui est déplacement en
hélicoptère le vent on sait que
transporte plus facilement le son aussi
donc forcément pour les arrivées les
hélicoptères ça va être pris en compte
pour pouvoir faire déposer au plus près
des zones ou dans des zones
particulières en fonction de l'ennemi
qu'on peut avoir en face
professionnelle aguerri les commandos
parachutistes font de cette contrainte
un véritable atout
deux jours comme de nuit et qu'importe
les conditions il s'adapte pour mener à
bien la mission
après 9 semaines d'entraînement
intensifs
bientôt les voiles direction le théâtre
d'opérations
[Musique]
des conditions extrêmes
tout au long de l'histoire la
météorologie est devenue une donnée clé
au bon déroulé des opérations
elle s'est imposée comme une science
essentielle pour les forces armées
les techniques ont évolué au fil du
temps jusqu'à permettre l'élaboration de
donner et de prévisions toujours plus
précise
analyse satellite ou encore calculatrice
les innovations météo ont su se rendre
essentiel pour contrer les phénomènes
alliés à Météo France les armées
françaises ont fait de la météorologie
un allié stratégique majeur les forces
sont désormais un coup d'avance pour
déjouer les éléments et faire de la
météo un atout opérationnel
[Musique]